the story about
George Bush Senior you know for many
years asked where were you on that day
were you in Dallas you were seen in
Dallas I wasn't in Dallas there's a lot
of talks about George Bush Senior if he
can pull up that one picture I just sent
you uh this one here if you zoom in a
little bit
you know that's uh him to the right on
how he stands and then that's him to the
left in Dallas
uh at the you know Book Depository so
you you hear why wasn't he there why
wasn't you know why wasn't why doesn't
he say where he was at why does he not
remember that was there any is there any
credibility to seniors involvement in
this you're asking yeah no
that that's not him the picture of him
in D Lee Plaza he was there the day
before okay the day of the assassination
he was in a little town called Tyler
Texas which I believe is a home of Earl
Campbell and he was uh he was addressing
a group of businessmen also also city of
uh um
The Legend yes
there were at least 100 people there
yeah okay so no that that's now what now
now if you're going to tell me was he
CIA did he concealed his I agree with
that you know when he became CI director
which I think was 75 or 76. you know he
he I believe he was dishonest when he
said he had no connections with this
yeah yeah so so okay so here's another
question for you with the family John F
Kennedy who who feared the the Kennedy
Legacy Family to think that maybe these
guys can be in office for 16 years you
know this could be a possibility where
you know John F Kennedy first eight and
then Bobby 8 16 Kennedys are going to be
you know running the country they're
going to have power over everything we
have to slow this down who feared for
the possibility of that happening you
wanna you wanna answer anything
I well I think I think that we we talked
about some of the you know
um uh in terms of economics I say a lot
of a lot of folks have theorized that it
was the uh the oil
industry as well but um in terms of
lbj's connection but there are a lot of
things as I mentioned before that the
Kennedy family you know a lot of people
didn't like them to begin with and feel
that they were worthy of holding office
um and at the same time they were
pushing an agenda that was changing the
course or threatened to change the
course and to to of the of America to
actually focus on other types of issues
and topics there were a lot of people
that were very uncomfortable with that
and again that's why it unrightly so uh
there have been like we looked at all
three we looked at Bobby Kennedy Martin
Luther King assassination and also
um JFK and just like if you look at the
hsca records
um you know having investigators
literally looking at primarily uh the
JFK and MLK as well and you can see that
even if you go to Memphis and and and
see the The sniper's Nest you know from
Martin Luther King and to see where they
talk about the work of the hsca you know
and all those different things so what
all the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valuetainment
it says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
are black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people wore it in the office they
had to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]